I like have daddy issues so I need like
reassurance and stuff like that yeah
oh yeah
let me just say this okay
calm down
how are you you make quite the entrance
and what makes you say that
um you're just like very out there like
very colorful I feel like you're kind of
a type person that kind of takes over
the room when you walk in thank you yeah
thank you I appreciate the fact that you
just kind of openly told me you're a
giant [ __ ] appreciate you yeah about to
hit this button on you so you can take
your black and white ass [ __ ] out of
here black and white ass black and white
white and black what was I supposed to
say I don't know I don't even know black
and white ass black and white because
she's wearing black and white
that's not what people are gonna think
well they're gonna think that you talk
about the fact that he looks mixed
Lord listen if I'm talking about a mixed
person I just say hybrids up for hybrids
they're more eco-friendly
okay
it has a better connotation you know I
mean you guys are better for the
environment you're the future so I'm
trying to say the hybrids of the future
you know
or if I want to be extra disrespectful
and almost like low-key like
discriminatory I'd be like half breeds
you know what I'm saying that's that's
that that's that that's that that's that
crazy talk that's not crazy oh here's
here's that little Half Breed I'm like
damn you talking about like that's crazy
that's how you used to talk about yeah
that's how they used to that was crazy
right I'm sorry okay before I go uh I
love your eyes thank you get out of here
this is fashion she said get out of here
lame-o here's the thing he was being
complimentary which I understand but you
also don't have to start your
compliments like she's above you how are
you good how are you doing pretty good
today honestly I want to say I love your
outfit I like the like color thing
you're going thank you yeah it's kind of
like a bisexual shirt yeah honestly buy
two same here yes why did you reject him
I think he might have been a a bit
younger than me a boy unless I said I
don't told you guys like when you guys
come into this Mission you guys look
listen being younger than a woman isn't
the issue no say it is it's not it's
about what it represents you get what
I'm trying to say I don't bagged enough
older women in 10 years 15 years okay
and and they might put up a little bit
like oh no I'm not open to it but they
really just sometimes just testing you a
little bit to see what you got going on
they put up the barrier but they haven't
closed the door they're still there
having a conversation that's your
opportunity to move on in right because
if she know you good you got your [ __ ]
together and you ain't living like a
little boy she gonna be with it
she gonna be with it especially when
you're coming with that young I mean
bedroom energy she's not gonna be
against it either so to all the young
guys watching you know I mean trying to
bang the older ladies it's not a problem
you can do it it's gonna be a little bit
harder the barrier the entry is a little
bit higher
but the possibility is there and that's
all we need you want to know why because
the penis is a dreamer and this is one
dream you can't achieve I vote for Abba
in 2024.
how are you doing you know I'm good how
are you good I'm faith I'm Emma hi nice
to meet you does Emma make you nervous
a little bit yeah why
why she wants somebody to just lay down
the law and just mash up her place you
feel me she wants somebody to come
through what place yeah I mean what
place she wants somebody to send her
walls you get what I'm trying to say
redo her pelvic floor yeah she wants you
to come in with Timberlands and be like
miss you ready to laugh knock knock
cause we gonna get these jokes let me
read the punchline this dick you get me
knock knock who's there
it's going down if I mean he's going
down you going down on me let's get it
pop you know what I mean that's what she
but all these people are like and they
melted in front of her no why are you
trying to so I mean we ain't trying to
hear that [ __ ] oh am I pretty oh yeah of
course oh smoke show yeah you heard that
she said smokes you're gorgeous you're
gorgeous she's still gonna bust her out
the first chance she gets [ __ ] you
fifty dollars what's something fun
you've done in the last week I went to
like my friends like house and went like
wine tasting nice oh hell yeah I love
that I'm sorry oh you're gorgeous you're
pretty watch I promise you some somebody
more mature gonna come in this [ __ ] no
no a whole ass stud they need she needs
if her whole ass does come out
not a stud she needs someone that's more
certain hello hello okay what should we
talk about
um do you like tattoos I do I don't have
any though you know what do you like in
terms of tattoos yes I do play a lot of
Dungeons and Dragons and but I think a
20-sided dice would be so adorable hey
hey I'm not even gonna lie I play DND
too tomorrow let's profit what you
rolling as a goblin a human a fur bog an
elf come on what level is your character
what campaign you playing in what kind
of listen you want to get a level five
Firebug Fireball going we can we get a
popping you know sorry Hey listen my
subclass player player come on
what is this role-playing aren't you Pro
BDSM
Pro what yeah you're like you're like
you're very like oh six positive like oh
you know the media is a pro BDSM where
the [ __ ] did you get that yeah yeah
you're always like six times you got a
whole podcast just being like Oh my God
these ladies doing The Nightlife are so
amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
like is is that what this is you know
like oh ladies that whole dungeon of
dragon [ __ ] that's what it was no no
he's like I don't like that
I don't appreciate it
oh yeah
let me just say this okay
calm down
like a [ __ ]
okay let me say this
on behalf y'all listen listen listen big
nerds in the building okay let me say
this okay
on behalf of the Nerds I resent the fact
that people are like oh my God don't
hate shame you know what I mean you
wanna do this you want to be into role
play whatever suits your boat and the
[ __ ] do role play for leisure
for fun games and everybody acts like
you you you you you you're a school
shooter in the making like we just
[ __ ] go in y'all [ __ ] wrote
dice over it it's what you mean you go
in and you have super powers those Super
Bowl Powers you guys are dick that's it
you [ __ ] out there on playing
[ __ ] laser swords or whatever the
[ __ ] you played yeah it's stupid it's
just stupid yeah only listen listen I'm
gonna put his [ __ ] Instagram right in
the pin comment all you nerds this is
your chance for some Revenge okay y'all
let them know how you feel about the
fact that he disrespected your heart I
don't give a [ __ ] okay
I didn't appreciate that suck my dick
yeah we're going to relive High School
all over again yeah yeah
put yourself in the locker and that's it
all right shout out to my DND nerds
that's right that was me and the lockers
back then but I'm taking my revenge on
you she come at me I'mma come at you
yeah she started talking about d d and
27-sided dice a little bit crazy for my
taste but you know shout outs to her I
appreciate them what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you know you have like I
don't want it yeah so sometimes you have
a 10-sided dice or one to ten one to
twenty she wants a 27 one for some
reason right
foreign
maker the first thing that people see
and you have to take care of that I
understand that it's not for everybody
it's not everybody that know how to do
it and know how to take care of their
skin well that's a wonderful timing that
you have here because we have this
wonderful project that I'm using to
clear off everything in my skin and my
Paws th H Henley what I would suggest
you to do I suggest you to take and to
start with the level one system because
it's a box what kind of products they
got in the Box I'm about to tell you
right now well first of all they have a
face wash they want to get all in the
nooks and crannies all the pores keep
all the grime out boom they have a
moisturizer as a SPF uh 20 in there you
don't want to have a little protection
from the Sun they have instruction with
the products that you're gonna use to
tell you when to use the products how to
use the products go on the link below
right now click on the link below and
save 30 off your first purchase and also
you can get a free gift from thiege
Henley I'm just saying if you wash your
booty wash your beauty
that was genius
Gabrielle Gabrielle and yours is nausea
oh here she comes trying to make new
friends like yo every time this girl's
on screenless let's be friends like
that's not what we're here for we want
to see somebody who might potentially
[ __ ] each other that's what we hear
Niger okay okay very nice to meet you so
tell me about yourself graphic designer
oh goodness
okay do you think that is cute yeah I
like your nose rings and I like your
tattoos oh thank you yeah yeah they're
fire do you think she's cute I do you're
you're an attractive human being
[Music]
an attractive human being thank you I
appreciate that what's your sexual
orientation me both of you I'm bisexual
pansexual
I I am
transgender that's your natural rotation
but whatever
well he's pansexual yeah he I haven't
dated other trans people but I'm open to
it what about you what do you mean like
because bisexual is like you could care
about the gender yeah
I do care about the gender
[Music]
okay
so I guess I was right all right
one
I'm just trying to understand that
conversation no no no no no no no no no
no because I need to break it down so
you're bisexual yeah as you do care
about the gender yeah
Panthers don't don't care
sure but you're trains right you went
from from from woman to man yeah so
you're part of the Buy
no
Japan
that has that's one thing
she talked about another thing
which means she's part of the body she's
not part of the Buy
okay let me let me try to understand
yeah go ahead if you say
bro this math is crazy okay because it's
a transgender pansexual non-conforming
gender binding you know I mean it's like
this is a sickness of the highest order
they are all engaging in confusion this
person okay
is
a trans man okay
she's open to bi people so yeah so both
both men and women who are you talking
about the girl she's open to men and
women the trans person no the girl the
girl
you said he was trans man if I said the
girl you should know who the [ __ ] that
was I was just testing yeah no I don't
know I'm testing you no I'm good listen
I'm good listen
how problematic that was no dead
neighborhood we're just trying to no no
don't crack as well don't crack as well
[ __ ] you know look at that face yeah
but I know I'm evil you need to admit it
too
but I know I'm evil and welcome to
today's episode of DnD yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
but yeah so
so the trans man no the girl you talk
about the girl the girls the girl is by
yeah he's paying okay meaning he's
attracting people's Personality yeah
she's attracted to people uh who fit
either binary but whatever beyond that
he thinks one of the binary
you get what I'm trying to say
he's a trans man yeah but I think the
the way the reason why he why he buzzed
was because they do not agree on what
the
care about see he doesn't care about
gender
she cares about gender it's like that's
a deal bringer to them that's the reason
why he Buzz okay that makes sense but my
my thing is okay hypothetical
if I say
I'm into women
and then the girl across from me says
she's into intelligence we can still
date we don't have to be into the same
things that's not that was the what what
she said was a deal breaker to him y'all
got stupid it's so stupid I don't care I
don't care about gender she said I care
about gender and it was like well deal
breaker that's it that's them
you're funny I just want to let you know
oh the [ __ ] friends think again
oh my God this always comes on trying to
make friends you said that bro that's
like people on Tinder like I'm just here
for friends
get on Facebook and start requesting
stupid why are you here
go on Instagram and slide in DMS hey no
don't even do that because they're not
trying to be friends there either
it is the best dating app it just
happens to be unofficial yeah
well she cared about the gender that's
it's just personal preference that's
cool you're right but like I thought we
were vibing though how are you I'm good
how are you is that only finance model
who got rejected by that woman because
apparently women don't want to date only
fans models either wow that's why I
could be Petty and remind everyone that
yeah
I like have daddy issues
so I need like reassurance and stuff
like that yeah naija reassure her give
her some compliments compliments okay
first thing I noticed
piercings love the piercings it's like
being eyes thank you that's perfect for
me yeah I mean I can show her you with
compliments oh thank you that's what I
like to hear are you sexually attracted
to each other I definitely am sexually
attracted thank you
um I'm not like super sexually attracted
to you yeah can I ask why why well just
because like since I've been like a
lesbian like most of my life and I just
recently started like dating guys and
stuff yeah but I'm always open to like
whatever you know I shared last time um
that I'm trans transgender oh really
yeah oh yes yes please don't act like
you didn't know she went she didn't say
oh really oh yeah
I know
so I don't know if that like plays into
your sexual reality it honestly
probably would so it depends on the
person definitely definitely and I'm
open-minded girl so you know we'll see
so
um what would you say you feel as like
spirituality like how do you feel about
that because I do like to go ghost
hunting okay
I mean I'll be honest with you I've had
some paranormal encounters oh really oh
my goodness she sounds like the most
unprofessional ghost hunter ever let's
say if you're really going for a ghost
I'm not going and you have to hire the
ghost monster she picks up like oh my
goodness welcome we're gonna be ghost
hunting today but first how about we
take a selfie I'm gonna go red one last
time and if neither of you hit me I I'm
setting you two up on a second date I'm
not gonna hit the butt okay I won't hit
it either
congratulations
I don't think so I think she really
opened minded to some people okay I want
you guys to appreciate something because
I actually like what this girl did what
you do
how many times have we seen people on
the come on the button and reject people
for the dumbest reasons well yeah he
just did okay
how many times have some of the ugliest
people come on the bun and rejected
people for the dumbest reasons fair and
now you have a relatively attractive
woman who comes on she's been on two
episodes been with people who are less
attractive than she was and she's been
open-minded both times I will say to her
defense and some I think is respectable
she's open-minded to some degree more so
than a lot of people who come on these
shows so even though we you know
critique people when they're hyper
critical the fact that she says you know
what I'm gonna just take a chance you're
interesting I'm not sure about like
let's see I think that's a good quality
sometimes people have such rigid things
when it comes to dating before they've
even done much dating and so they're
already causing themselves from
experiences that they might actually
enjoy because they were like no that's a
red line for me it's like [ __ ] you drew
that red line when you were like 18 and
you've never even been inside a [ __ ]
what do you you don't know what a red
line is you have no reason why you even
Drew you just heard something on a
podcast or somebody told you you don't
know so I think people like her in a way
especially considering her career being
open-minded makes me respected I think
it's commendable maybe maybe it's just
because of her career she has no choice
to be open-minded like she don't have
the choice to be that much like super
strict and [ __ ] like that like not much
[ __ ] are gonna put up with
whatever the hell you're doing the fact
that is what it is maybe so maybe it's
maybe it's that maybe let me ask you
though go ahead
she does only fans it makes it harder
for her right yeah okay
this being ugly make it harder for you
yeah how many ugly people came on this
show and still were unreasonable yeah
okay
I'm just saying yeah in fact most of the
unreasonable people we saw so far were a
lot of the ugly people and so I can
appreciate not so much how ugly you is
how much you think about yourself and
how much you have a chance to know like
the thing that happened with the button
how it's not real and it's not really
based on ugly or not and the fact that
you're now you're on the same Level
Playing Field if you're ugly or not it's
not it doesn't matter because the
rejection is not me saying ew you're not
coming to me the button put us together
see that's why it's we can't take it
like that because the button put us
together and the only thing that's going
to make me reject you I could actually
reject you as much as you can reject me
whereas in real life is if I come up to
me if I come up to you and you see me
you reject me you know I mean and the
button is not really
that's the thing so
because the button can put [ __ ]
at the same Level Playing Field where
it's really just a question of speed
more of a question of I'm ugly and
you're pretty right or how I think about
myself or whatever it's whoever's gonna
be like I can actually reject you I have
if I'm quick enough not based on my look
in real life
if I'm ugly I'm gonna get more rejected
more but you understand what I'm saying
we agree on that I want to make sure
because I'm saying the sex worker is
open-minded and so that's why she's
giving more success with this stuff
she's being patient She's Not Just
swiping the next person she's being open
mind with whoever she chooses yeah the
other people are not and having less
success right so my point being is I
commend her because she's open-minded
with who she's choosing with that okay
and so she's having more success whereas
the ugly people who have less to offer
are coming on and being more demanding
okay so we agree we agree on that okay
so then I think the day the point still
stands which is what's good about the
sex worker in this case the person that
we're talking about right is she came on
she says
I'm gonna just see what it is I'm gonna
meet whoever and even if it's not great
I'ma look at it for what it is the ugly
people come on and be like I'm gonna be
super demanding and this and that
because now they can
because they're disillusioned
yes
because this is not
Mickey oh and they are you don't think
ugly people are not disillusioned in
real life sure but if you say so if you
say they are they are do you think ugly
people so wait all those women going on
Kevin Samuels live who are fat
overweight and say want a million
dollars are they not disillusioned yeah
I'm not saying the opposite I said yeah
they are a decision but then why are you
saying in real life they're not that's
why I'm confused not as much they have
more chances to be delicious
they they have more chances of acting
like that the way they're acting right
now people are just like oh yeah there's
you know just just I'm better than
whatever the hell I am they have more
chances on the button because they have
a sense of competition and it's really
just about speed that in real life where
in real life they're really just gonna
be like swipe okay yeah next but I I
have all the work to do whereas the
button the button brings the next person
I don't have to go I don't have to go
swipe I don't have to do that so it
amplifies
the fact that they are
disillusioned yeah so it doesn't that
mean that the sex worker is even better
as a result yes because even though that
disillusion is there she doesn't bite
into it whatsoever yes okay
yeah
that's all huh what'd you say I said
glad we had that talk
anything else no this sounds like there
is you roll in your eyes go ahead no I'm
good
well